you
you can't play jazz without mastering
improvisation and if I make the metaphor
that a photo session is like is like
jazz that's you know because there's
interaction between the players and your
get you're trying to get to it the
emotional core of things and it's paying
attention to each other and capturing
something you're after something
together
last you know even though it's not a
session I mean I have a I have a
photograph of Francis Ford Coppola that
I particularly loved it was just one
frame shot at an ocean with a play
camera but it's waiting for that right
moment and that right exchange there's
photo sessions that last 11 hours and
the person feels like they've done
battle and you know in the end end end
of their worst battle fatigue let's do
one more roll and the picture comes
there so sometimes and it has to do also
with the person's the person's self
knowledge and confidence there are
certain people that you don't have to
even work at extracting their inner life
it's just there and they're happy to
share with you Bobby short you know I
think the third frame that I took being
being being that's Bobby he had nothing
to hide loves who he is knows who he is
and other people a little bit of digging
sometimes